gallop's been doing this pull for the  last eight years since 1940 okay and the  whole poll is about a better job  handling problem you think most  important who Republicans Or democrats  do you trust can do do can do a better  job handling problems today and this is  Gallup the same facts the same CNN okay  48 said Republicans 37 said Democrats  today and here's the crazy thing about  this data since 1940 when they started  doing this poll  the widest margin they've ever had was  17 points in 1946  Truman was President this is right after  nuke you know 1945 1946 the American  people went towards Republicans over  Democrats 11 is the second largest since  1946 the highest since 1946